Spain's Socialist Party has been handed a lifeline
after hardline Catalan nationalist
voted in support of their candidates
parliamentary speaker
the resulters boosted Pedro Sanchez's hopes
of securing another term as prime minister
following last months inconclusive elections
the pro Catalan independence gents party
voted in favour of Francina Armengol becoming speaker
in exchange for concessions
including the use of regional languages
in parliament
the party maintains that they will only support
making Sanchez prime minister
in exchange for an independence referendum
and amnesty for those charged
in connection with their failed 2017 referendum
however as far as Sanchez
and his Socialist Workers Party is concerned
this is a non starter
as it force foul off the institution
the Zhuntz party became potential kingmakers
following the July election
which saw Sanchez's party and its allies win 171 seats
while the right wing opposition block
also secured 171 seats
leaving both blocks
short if the 176 needed for a majority
and making Zhuntz's seven seats crucial